I think welcome back to the daily
podcast first podcast up to k7
teens one seven Congrats
hey ooh kill him new year new year same
same day same week new year new year are
you living I'm living in what guys
welcome back to the jinjo podcast we are
so excited to be back here we missed you
we took Christmas off we hope you guys
had a wonderful holiday with your family
your friends yourself your dog oh
whatever you're doing we hope it was
good and we are back
it is 2017 we are [ __ ] here we're
[ __ ] here to stay it's an actually
New Year's day for us it's literally
generous like a hangover City right now
you know what I think that's something
that people appreciate about our podcast
is that when we're [ __ ] hung over in
podcasting we transfer girl it's a mess
over Oh on that note this episode is
brought to you by nature box for all
your snacking needs whether you're
hungover or not nature box is there for
you with delicious snacks they have over
a hundred choices savory sweet delicious
all of them and they're adding new
snacks all the time right now you get
your first two snacks free going to
naturebox.com/tyler Julianne that's us
snacks are for you check it out also
brought to you by lift lift is looking
for a whole bunch of new female drivers
so ladies if you want to drive for lift
make your own hours use your own car and
make a bunch of money right now they are
offering a $500 driver bonus when you
sign up using our URL which is lift calm
slash Jenna Julianne that's us thank you
to our sponsor AG sponsors
I would love some [ __ ] nature box
right now title nature's books I am
hungry eat nature books image of books
on Pumbaa you just need so we're talking
about to that bit bit ah first thing
that I want to talk about honestly is
that legendary iconic Mariah Carey New
Year's Eve performance because I tweeted
something out
for those who didn't see it it was the
New Year's rockin Eve yes yes yeah so it
was hosted by Ryan Seacrest who works
closely with the e Network yes this was
like so outrageously bad like clearly
they were sound issues she was saying I
can't hear or whatever and like honestly
it might be go down in history is like
one of the worst live performances ever
like it was just so outrageously bad
there was bad on on all the levels like
every level it could have been bad on it
was bad right so she started off like
lip-synching a song and then she walks
out to the front of the state you can
see it online I'm sure you know what I'm
talking about if you don't you should
look it up and she starts being like we
can hear it's okay though and all of
those dancers in the background were
like I'm not losing my job today I'm not
losing my they were teasing hard they
were the show goes on no matter whether
the show goes on but they were also kind
of hard proof that they didn't have your
pizzas and they don't wanna be yet so
well obviously she can hear somewhat
it's not like she's deaf right the
juniors somewhat but it is not ideal
when you can't on your singing in Times
Square and you can't heat like yeah
that's a big [ __ ] up on somebody's part
whatever yeah somebody probably got
fired for it but that doesn't make that
doesn't like that happens probably a lot
and right you don't see how these happen
like that a lot how many times have do
you imagine that this has happened to
Mariah Carey personally over the span of
her career probably a lot yeah and we've
all seen it happen too with other
artists and they do this thing where
they try their best and then we'll be
laughing or like saying something
improvised yeah you're forced to
improvise you do the best that you can
or you tweet then later like sorry I was
off-key I could hire myself yeah people
are like oh cool man whatever yeah I I
mean the theory though but this was so
shocking ready guys to k17 conspiracies
start right now
I will guy already tweeted it it was Joe
shockingly bad that this was a PR move
you know this is New Year's Eve you have
people all around the world
so many people are gonna see this and
you know it even if they're not watching
it live they'll see it so you think your
promo mariah's world's on the E Network
we just so happen like okay I looked it
up Ryan Seacrest is not executive
producer on Mariah's world but I feel
like the world of E is not too big right
such a far-fetched idea that New Year's
rockin Eve is hosted and produced by
Ryan Seacrest
Mariah has a show on the E Network this
is an amazing amount of publicity for
that show alone and then all of a sudden
she does this like I literally was like
cackling laughing and I was like if I
was Mariah right now I'd be like yo I
can't hear myself but make sure you
watch Mariah's world on E like you know
just throw in some [ __ ]
yeah so I have a question well it felt
like a purposeful bomb so what do you
think Ryan had to do with it you think
he was part of he like he sabotage if
okay well just buy into the theory for a
second of it if this was a plan I'm
talking when I say inside role job I
mean like maybe her people people who
are tube not like NBC trouble of course
yeah so her PR team is like hey Mariah
take the dive yeah take the dive
leadership they didn't tell her dancers
you know like they only told Mariah and
at one point they like come up for mic
at the end yes so you should've clarify
you think Ryan Seacrest was happy that
it went badly yeah or maybe Ryan knew
and then she and her and her people knew
it's just a theory
because immediately after he's like no
matter what Mariah does her fans love it
no her family's such like a quick almost
concocted reaction to what just happened
very back here legendary miss of what
just happened well it felt very
backhanded for a number of reasons like
one of which and Ryan knew this is that
allow the b-roll was used to cover up
her [ __ ] show and the b-roll as much as
you'd like to think it's just screaming
fans it wasn't it was like a lot of
confused faces and and people talking I
wasn't saying well when you're in Times
Square I imagine you do you don't have a
the best view of the actual of course
because I didn't even really see it was
here the vocal tract yeah hello
everything's normal what I'm saying is
they weren't going nuts whatever they
were doing they he said when I was you
directly in front of Mariah that was
going like that they said whatever you
do your fans always love it and they
just that was not indicative indicated
in the in the b-roll
but I have a question though because
before the performance even started they
did a little interview and he said so
tell us about your new reality show and
then she merely says well I just told
you not to call it that do you remember
that well she said I didn't name it that
let's not call it batters no no she says
I just told you as if they had talked
about it off camera I like distinctly
remember her saying I just said or I
just told you we would like to call a
reality show okay and so that kind of
backs up your theory that he was you
know happy to see this this train wreck
well why not like this we know that like
when you're doing a live performance
yeah no matter whether it's good or bad
like sometimes there are people like a
Miley Cyrus that goes out with the
intention of shocking off like this is a
good example of not a wardrobe
malfunction you know not somebody
falling down or this is just I'm gonna
go out there and pretend like nothing's
working
yeah Garrett you're guaranteeing
discussions exactly even if the Girt
about like it's one of those things like
any press is good press right right and
all people retweeting your tweet that
was like right after she should should
happen so I hope you have a happy and
healthy New Year and out and Brett or
someone was like oh good for Mariah
that's a good response and I was like
Mariah good for her PR people that is a
you think Mariah Carey uses her own
phone boy boo
come on she uses if I can t crash she
doesn't she doesn't tweet for herself is
what we're saying and she doesn't text
for yourself or take on concerts or in
scriptures do anything for but I will
say that we observed she looked quite
Spacey like throughout the entire
evening even before the performance she
looked like she was on some some good
stuff
and couldn't really focus she was just
out of it she it seemed like she was
just like oh well [ __ ] it I got to do
this this little dumb gig in New Year's
and Here I am
all right great oh and then it just
happened to be like a terrible
performance I mean even that aside is it
too far-fetched to imagine someone's
inner circle of people being like just
go out there and bomb and everyone will
be talking about you tomorrow so my
question is do you think is part of your
theory to say that there was no
technical malfunction at all she just
turned her - yeah or could it have been
that her team manufactured a technical
difficulty I mean that's possible i
watch on real yeah that's they can pull
strings are right that's possible yeah
interesting is it too far-fetched to a
magic show you guys catch mirai's world
on us
so maybe yeah no I I don't I don't think
your theory is even really I mean it is
conspiracy wherever but I don't think
it's far-fetched I think it's very
believable very you know it's it's
something that doesn't really take a lot
- we're not talking about it we're all
talking about it here we are promoting
her what is her [ __ ] is it just a
reality thing is well yeah is it a first
reality it's a reality show yeah but she
doesn't want you to call it that and
then right so this is like what would
you like me to call it she's like I
don't know not that what like what
you're on e and it's called Mariah's
world and you don't want it to be called
a reality show oh yeah I don't know so
that's weird
Twitter she kind of raised me up a
little bit yeah when I look at her face
I don't know what's going on behind her
face okay chilly tomorrow Happy New
Year's my hair look you gotta give
respect where respect is due she's still
Mariah Carey and part of her endearing
miss is that she is this over-the-top
diva it makes it endearing she's my wife
Christmas is you
that's her song yeah and 70 white roses
in my dressing room
what please
like a writer it is famously hysterical
uh-uh
got it Mariah's she's good she's a good
person I'm she's pretty cool like ever
the podcast
Ronna set her right sorry sorry you oh
you gave me a complete opportunity oh
it's an SMS I think the funniest idea
about you just saying we should have her
on the podcast which is ridiculous and
whatever but you can't even identify a
Mariah Carey song if I played you one
play me one I'll identify right away are
you kidding me this is all good I can't
do that Julia you said play me a song
like play a plan variety firm that is
all of them for Christmas is you name
another one okay dad the hall I recall
correctly when we did the julienne sucks
at celebrity trivia music to death what
well I'll find the time soon you put it
in the car if she ever when it is I
played you a part of the song fantasy
which was off of her number-one album
which went straight to number one
fantasy and you literally said to me
I've never heard that song before no I
know what I literally hadn't I didn't
know who she is
when I heard that song she didn't sing
that so like I know that you may be my
face makes you uncomfortable or whatever
you said she's somewhere I care I don't
she's a legend you love dishonor
standing of who bra he killed oh no I
know I know I mean like here's the thing
about here's the thing about the way my
brain works when it comes to this stuff
okay
it's she wasn't I know in their final oh
[ __ ] no no like I
I've heard all her music no no no let me
know you have it let me finish
I've heard a significant amount of her
popular popular music what from just let
me finish the thought before you ask
that question I've heard a lot of her
very popular music that everyone has
heard but I don't know it by name I've
heard the song I know the song I've
heard it a billion times like everyone
else I just don't know the name of the
song and maybe that put two into to get
I just know that I've heard her [ __ ]
that's it
okay so I understand the significance of
who Mariah Carey is I'm not under a rock
I know she's incredibly popular I know
she's a legend but at the same time I'm
allowed to have my thoughts about how
she acts on camera and I think it's
uncomfortable kind of uncomfortable can
you name any of the songs that she sang
last night during her performance oh
yeah let's think about that hmm
you watched it happens like every time
melon was that was that no Claire is it
no you're making no no no no where she
gets a really high note you don't talk
about that song come on what about song
ha yeah I go what yeah the one I need
baby it's you come on baby it's you all
I want for Christmas is you that is are
two different song Oh name another my
Carrie song just one more oh say can you
see no seriously
hi I'm trying being serious I'm trying
why do you want to hit kinda hit small
head just know what name one more me
people you know come on I need a hint or
else I quit just think for a second okay
ah that one no you put me on the spot I
can't think I'm sorry if you ever been
put on the spot you know like your brain
gets a block on it you can't think I
can't think well we're the what you sing
three four songs I sing zero songs last
night okay fair but what were they yo yo
honey
young no she's saying that that's called
love on top by Beyonce that's Mariah she
sang it last night oh right no well is
it a different one I think it might have
been different I excuse you it's okay
[Music]
someone save me no what would you rather
me be like a rag Carrie connoisseur I
know every one of your songs don't [ __ ]
that actually yeah that'd be really fun
Raya Carrie Thomas Thomas or that's my
new Twitter man all right Julia let's
move on oh is that it you don't you
you're interested in me talking about my
anymore no you can't name the songs that
you performed last night I can't I can
just give me a second any silence okay
hmm any noise will mess me up completely
so no no no noise yeah I can't think of
it
how does they can I'm sorry alright
let's talk about something else okay
let's talk about Ronda Rousey all right
so also this last weekend there was a
UFC 207 Ronda Rousey lost her second
consecutive fight likely likely people
are speculating her last fight got
knocked out pretty badly by Amanda
newness and it made big news obviously
because Ronda Rousey is a big name and
she came into the sport of MMA with such
dominance in star power and it all
happened so fast
to the part where she was beating chicks
with her judo and then somehow loses
terribly you know twice in a row like a
year apart like she just did and I
wanted to talk about I mean obviously
there's a lot being talked about whether
she's gonna retire why she lost that bad
what happened to her you know I mean
like a lot of casual fans who watched
her and don't understand I just think
there's well I mean just for off the top
this isn't going to be a very riveting
discussion because we're both on the
same page about this there's we don't
really have conflicting viewpoints right
we're not going to debate what I just
wanted to say that this is a great
example of her coach picking the wrong
coach he's the absolute wrong coaching
drag him I'll tell you something in a
minute but do you ednan Tarbert Ian
is a quote on quote MMA coach and for
some [ __ ] weirdo reason she ended up
at his tiny weird creepy Glendale gym
and he had been reaping the benefits of
having her be his fighter for so many
years because she is a Olympic medalist
judoka which nobody is and so she had a
skill level that nobody had and was
beating girls like nobody could so she
essentially won all those fights herself
I personally think that he did nothing
if anything and also the sport but the
female MMA was in its infancy there was
it I said this to you before it's like
the females when they first started in
the UFC was like when the UFC first
start when there was a specialist in
this fighting a specialist in this they
didn't know how to fight I was a [ __ ]
show there was a jiu-jitsu fighter
versus a boxer and it would just be like
the clashing of two different martial
arts and nobody knew how to do
everything
and that's no exception around I think
Ronda was obviously a grappler in judo
guy and then you you have girls like me
should tape who's a wrestler she
wouldn't how to strike anything it
developed but early on Ronda was finding
a lot of very one-dimensional fighters
and she was in is a one-dimensional
fighter and I say is because she decided
to go with the team and a coach who
didn't develop her as a fighter
they didn't didn't work on striking at
all I mean you look at the fight with
Nunez Nunez sorry and you can there's
zero striking training there's zero
striking skill there's no head movement
there's no footwork there's no anything
that even a week two weeks a month in a
real boxing coaches tutelage would have
learned and it's I just I couldn't
resting then it's like a very basic [ __ ]
I can learn my leaving that camp that
after the fight with Holly Holm a
devastating loss for her you know we we
talked about some theories about whether
or not we thought that she was gonna
come back or had the mental capacity to
pick herself back up yeah I honestly
thought that she was going to go a
hardcore back to her judo roots and that
she was going to show us a really you
know nice and quick [ __ ] armbar
I think a lot of people were expecting
that but instead she went out there and
I set you right after that fight she
changed literally nothing nothing she
spent all that time training gathering
herself this I'm not doing press you
know this I'm totally focused which fine
maybe you are but we both have opinions
and many people do about her ability to
do that because Conor McGregor got in a
lot more trouble for doing that one time
let alone up leading up to an entire
fight like why should the rules be
different for you just because you would
like to focus it is part of your job
description as a fighter to sell fights
and you're not doing that so then you're
like alright maybe she's that focus and
Dana's giving her special treatment to
do this for me she's gonna go back to
she's gonna yes you go back to the
drawing board start from square one and
build up a new way to fight yeah or go
back to what has made her that success
yes unfortunate goes there and it's like
you she trained exactly the same she did
exactly everything the same and expected
to win that fighter I hate to say crazy
I hate to say I told you so because I
[ __ ] did I literally right before I
fight said no matter what happens I
tweeted this what happened to this fight
Ronda already lost because she still
with this [ __ ] of a coach who hasn't
developed her at all because he doesn't
know what he's doing and you see that
and it's it's tragic because it's like
either Ronda was gonna get lucky clinch
Amanda and somehow throw her in armor
which could have happened Tona or she
was gonna get her ass knocked out what
she did and I think there I don't know
why I don't even really want to think
about the personal dynamic of why
someone stays with a coach like that
because it's really kind of [ __ ] oh
sure it's complicated I'm sure it's very
complicated and and island kill
speculate so much I just think that it's
such a it's such a joke that she decided
to stick with him and in turn do this to
her career I personally think that she's
young and talented enough to move camps
now for both of these laughing sorry and
still have an MMA career where she
actually puts up a fight against
strikers which I think is in essence
what everyone wants every words they
want to watch well she can make that
decision though continue to fight I
wanted to tell you I read an interesting
article I don't remember his name you
can look it up somehow somewhere watch I
did
it might have been MMA some MMA fighter
they might have been I'm fighting in my
head it was it sounds like that he had
written it almost immediately after and
was like I wrote this kind of draw but
he posed like a really interesting idea
about Edmond already and that may be
because Rhonda is sort of you know we
know her nuances that she's a little
crazy that she does do things Rhonda's
way and no other way she's very
sensitive she has a particular style of
how she likes to you know be in the zone
or have her attitude or whatever yeah
that all these people being like if only
she had a real striking coach or she
went over to Jackson she did something
like that she could have been so much
better yeah he theorized that if Rhonda
had done that earlier on in her career
that maybe she would have gotten in her
own way and not ever become Ronda Rousey
because she would have wouldn't have the
mental capacity to be criticized and
broken down all day every day that's
part of that now you stay with a guy
again and you're in your comfort zone
you're getting built up constantly but
well I mean just and you can read out
find the link for you like imagine now
she finds this coach ed Ben who is
building her up and giving her what she
needs to be successful no Sabrina and he
really did take her as far as she could
go because if she which we all have
talked about this and would like it if
she went and found a real striking coach
and a fight camp yeah like we like to
imagine that she'd come out of there an
incredible fighter but maybe she
couldn't get through that camp because
it would be too difficult for her to
take that type of crisis I think you're
right in a timeline Dana I said before I
think I think that theory is right in a
timeline where she would go to this new
second camp before she had lost because
before she lost she was invincible right
nobody could touch her anyone who tried
had their arm broken in ten seconds that
was
was the reality she had star power like
nobody had had before like she was being
built up by the UFC on a ridiculous
level because of this invincibility
factor so for a fighter like that to
show up at a new gym be like hey I need
to learn how to strike that's a huge hit
to your giant ego you're right it's like
this is a great theory what I'm saying
and I think you know to piggyback off of
that theory is once the Holly Holm fight
ends you really need to have a hard
think about why you lost so them and a
hard reset
well yeah but you need to sit by
yourself with your mother in the fetal
heart who actually care about you and
know what they're talking about which
her mother has been a very outspoken
hater on already invite which I
appreciate she keeps it way too [ __ ]
real and I love that um but yeah I mean
that was I think after the Holly fight
obviously this is this is no genius
[ __ ] theory here is you need to think
about what you're doing and you go back
to the drawing board and say how can I
improve myself oh is is staying with
Edmund and hitting his pads and to end
being told I'm a champ all day gonna
help me okay great man see what happens
called her out for that too yeah I mean
I put it in her mind that she is a boxer
she said that I'm innocent it was a
crazy thought put into her mind by her
coach that she can box which is it's
true and it's sad and I I I don't know I
think I think I don't know if she'll
ever be champ again if she keeps
fighting and goes to a new camp but I
know that she can do better than she did
the last two fights because it doesn't
really get much worse well I mean this
has to be a rock bottom of one kind or
another for her this was either a rock
bottom for her for a career like he
can't come back or it's a rock bottom
for her to truly decide to start over
which includes you know fixing other
people around you and she's been told
for years to get rid of Edmund this
might be if she chooses the rock bottom
of I'd like to keep moving forward
that's where you have to start she knows
that this time you can't you can no
longer silence these people and say
Edmonds one of the best in the world
he's great
you guys are all just drunk and crazy
this is that shows itself yeah
ability to do that anymore we can't
defend that any longer
well I really do I agree on things and
come down to her deciding that she needs
to make a change if she wants to have a
future in the sport which I think she
could be a great top-tier fighter and
and have success against other
well-rounded MMA fighters because when
you learn how to strike you don't just
stand there and get your [ __ ] head
popping off like a punching bag like
she's done twice in a row now it's you
know if she did that though she could be
an incredibly talented fighter of course
that's that that's the tragic part of
this whole situation is like she is so
amazing at one thing and if she just
sharpened up her game around the edges
with the rest of the mixed martial arts
then she could be unbelievable it's it's
a lot like when Demian Maia came into
the sport of MMA a world jiu-jitsu
Champlin a world renowned jiu-jitsu
practitioner everyone in jiu-jitsu knew
who he was he was amazing but at the end
of the day it's not jujitsu it's MMA so
he was struggling he was a mid-tier
fighter he would lose to strikers and
wrestlers and so finally he was like you
know I need I need to learn how to punch
I need to learn how to [ __ ] punch and
box and he did and now he's literally
one of the best I know in his division
because he learned how to round out
himself he's he's an expert at one thing
and he's decent at the rest
Ronde BMI is what close to 40 no he's
not young yeah I didn't make you late
there if you're that gifted in one
particular area of MMA and you round out
your game and you know given your
physical condition stage okay you can as
an older person continue to fight in
this war and fight for the title it's
not like in the top three right now is
that Lee's Demian Maia is such a great
example of an MMA fighter learning how
to become from a specialist and one
thing to a specialist as well as a
fighter and in a you know a competitor
and all the other things mixed martial
arts it's not just one more flower
that's a good struggling thing everyone
is hoping for for Ronda and saying that
I mean there's a lot of nasty [ __ ]
that's being said about oh it's garbage
it's really sad but most of it is should
be directed towards the fact that this
Edmond already in it like
really stole her career movie robbed her
he manipulated her he you know told her
that they were training everything was
good that he's he's world class and
she's a great striker it's a great
disservice and it's incredibly sad well
something I said to you the other day
when we were talking about this and I
wanted to talk I want to bring it up
here because I think it's really
important I trained you to I've trained
you to for years I have been around the
sport of MMA for a lot of years and I
used to cover it I actually went to MMA
gyms shooting video and interviewing
professional UFC fighters Julian's
interviewed us well I've spent a lot of
time around professional UFC fighter yet
special advisors top-tier fighters in
the gym and also just interviewing them
wherever and one thing I've really
really strongly come to understand is
that as an MMA fighter and I think this
applies to a lot of sports but as anime
fighter your training consists of they
like to say iron sharpens iron right
you're not going in the gym to come out
feeling good you don't go to the gym to
be like Oh everyone's pumping me up
everyone's telling me I'm great every
pad I hit sounds great oh it's all good
you don't go for that feeling you get
your nasty every day go to find your
flaws and you go to it like expose those
flaws over and over and over and
training and tilt are not there anymore
and that sucks that's a brutal life and
some of these fighters have to go
through some of the worst most like dark
like violent hard injured from injury
prone training sessions over and over
for years to become the fighters that
they become and what I think is Rhonda
went into the gym every day and had her
ego pumped up by Edmond because that was
a way for Edmond to keep her controlled
and it you know maybe maybe her ego
could have handled a true MMA training
gym or maybe it couldn't have but we'll
never know unless she were to go try it
out well I read in that article this may
not be right or wrong as I haven't
looked into it myself that she had some
public stats with her judo coaches in
the past is that true I think I'm
talking about that to you her mom is
judo coach for a while but yeah I think
she's she's had a history of that I
think you you have a history of not
getting along with the people who are in
theory like in power control position
try a letter you by doing right but if
you have these sort of really public
fights or whatever with your coaches
yeah it doesn't maybe we'll give you
them out of the doubt that maybe those
coaches weren't a good fit or maybe they
were wrong because coach is gonna be
[ __ ] wrong all the time yeah but maybe
that doesn't give the best indicator of
how she would take a true striking coach
is feedback you might yeah how can she
handle feedback yeah yeah yeah because
you I've had bad coaches you've had bad
coaches you know that one of the only
ways ever win in that situation is to
short it like shut your [ __ ] mouth
just take their advice and shut up yeah
yeah
remember that you are not the coach they
are right even if you think they're
wrong you're not the coach exactly until
you have an opportunity to maybe switch
teams or go somewhere else like when I
was in college I had a coach that I very
openly disagreed with and it got me
nothing but trouble until I just shut my
[ __ ] mouth my junior year of high
school some way I my juniors shot my
mouth my entire life to all my coaches
except for one who was doing some
off-the-field very not okay things yeah
and I said something and I was spring
training she benched me I was supposed
to start she [ __ ] bengaline same
thing happen to me my mom was like why
aren't you on the field and I was like
dude [ __ ] that [ __ ] benched me yep I
my junior year I was in high school I
was a catcher and I was a junior varsity
starting right and I started and I
played the first entire half of the
season consecutively and I remember that
specifically because one of our pitchers
ty o Skaggs had 40 Scouts in the back
and so every game I caught of his it was
like crazy was amazing and I got into it
with my coach all the time because I
hated him and everyone hated him but I
particularly hate him because he would
try to alter the game he would you try
to control how I caught which is a very
you know pitcher catcher relationship
timing you [ __ ] with that and we would
we would quad heads all the time and
then suddenly midseason
I'm not starting anymore and then for
the rest of season he put in a worst
defensive catcher than me and it was
because I couldn't just shut the [ __ ] up
and you learned that as an athlete and
part of me really believes that a
Veronica
it were to or even in the future goes to
a Greg Jackson or a Tristar a K whatever
anywhere with real coaches she would
have a learning curve but she would
eventually fit in and learn how to be a
teammate and learn how to better herself
right with time training because where
she is although there are some other
people who have gone to Glendale to have
Edmond trained she's not necessarily
part of a team culture no there is no
team cult exactly so if if she did and
judo is not a team sport like there I
think there's a reason and a type of
person that maybe thrives in an
individual sport so Imran is a person
that thrives in an individual sport
because all of her hard work pays off
for just her and you know she there's no
one else around her that she wants to
blame for not putting in the same level
of effort or work or whatever if she
truly decided now as a how old is she 30
yeah somewhere between 29 year-old 30
year old woman that like hey I need to
understand what it's like to rely on
other people and delegate some of this
work around which includes your coach
knowing what's right for you and you
listening to them instead of you needing
to know everything yeah you know I mean
she had someone in her corner that was a
really good corn iment like it takes a
lot of learning so early when you're so
used to doing it all yourself well in
your mind it's it's you know did she had
that learning curve with judo she has to
have because she became one of the best
in the world in judo so the thing is she
starts judo and from the point when she
started that sport to winning a bronze
in the Olympics in judo there is a lot
of learning but when she's learned
enough to be that good she immediately
is a top the game and that doesn't
happen in MMA no one's that high and
even the people who are champs they have
team team of fighters around them who
are constantly exposing different flaws
and so first she was like oh I'm the
best in judo now so I can take that
mindset to MMA what you can't do in a
minute here and you're right there's
zero team atmosphere zero team at
Glendale so you know right well I guess
we'll see I really I really do hope that
she can find her way to a real camp
I hope should shew I think most people
do you know
yeah but I'm fully expecting her to
retire I'm not I'll tell you one thing
I'm not expecting her to fight again
under admin I think I think even she
isn't dumb rock bottom one way or
another I think it's either retirement
or square one I have my fingers crossed
for square one because I'd like to see
her fighting me too me too I personally
think that she can really lift her head
up don't you oh my god what are you
doing speaking of lips that is brought
to you by live ladies are you an actress
who wants to make money in between jobs
or are you looking for a job right now
or maybe you're at school and you have
some hours a time where you can be
making some money lift is great for you
you can become a driver right now it is
very easy there are other ride-sharing
apps out there but everyone likes
driving for lyft best because they treat
their drivers right there's a really
flexible way to make money you pick your
own hours you drive your own car
what what did I do I'm just talking
about driving for lyft pays up to 35 an
hour 35 dollars an hour and getting
started is fast and easy you can drive
mornings nights weekend or you can
literally just flip in the driver mode
if you have some free time and you're
out only lyft drivers can earn tips from
with an app and those add up fast also
you don't have to wait days or weeks to
get paid you can cash out instantly with
Express pay it's super flexible you keep
your own tips and you get paid when you
the extra cash ladies right now if
you're looking for some sort of way to
make some money lyft is a great way to
do it right now you can get a $500
driver bonus by going to lift calm slash
Jenna Julian that's lyft calm slash and
Julian thank you lift other sponsor this
week is the beautiful and wonderful
nature box the company that makes
strawberry carrot Fruit Chews
my bay to the stars I love them so much
the Mesa crisp they have over a hundred
delicious delicious snacks hot tasty
made with simple ingredients and they
deliver it right to your door so you can
always have something better than a
crown without feeling guilty and it's
really great right now you can go to
naturebox.com/tyler Julian and you get
your two free snacks but the way it
works is you go pick yourself
they send me your house and you eat them
it's not simple and if you don't like a
snack you can get your refund on that
snack I doubt you will dislike it
because all their snacks are delicious
but right now you get your two free
snacks and you can try it out and you
can avoid the guilt because naturebox is
made with real ingredients and um we we
don't have any cuz I ain't all of it I
need some nature bot H is the story of
my life and hung over from New Year's
that I need major bob you know naturebox
is great so right now guys if you want
to have awesome snacks go to nature
lifestyle calm slash annejulien they
have a great variety and they're
constantly adding new snacks based on
customer feedback which is really cool
they're adding new snacks all the time
they don't stay the same and you can get
any of the snacks you'd like right now
thank you to our sponsors thank you
sponsors I just lay here like the new
year new sponsors just kidding oh gee
fan obviously and ready to mingle a cast
my cast 2k 17 I guess we'll probably
gotta focus know now is that time when
we just start writing the wrong date on
all of your things
yeah so how long is that pier to get a
list like at least a year until next
mariah carey performance yeah I've been
writing 19.95 on all of my papers
actually that when you're born no joke
yeah Marlon was born in 93 Julian do you
know what year I was born in 86 I know
your birthday of our heart I say it all
the time you know that I know you were
born in 1992 baby it's the buthey and
I'm an Aries I'm an Aries in 92 I was
90s kid that face when you're a 90s kid
the [ __ ] does that have to do with
anything I don't know all right so what
do you hope happens next year this wait
no this year's it's already next year so
that means so much like what I want
another dog okay me too
wholeheartedly I just want another dog
we I'd say it's one of the top ask
questions is when when you guys getting
another dog and we always say oh we want
another dog but like I really feel like
we need to wait until we don't rent
more but we want to rescue a greyhound
we've been looking into it hardcore
although there are some ways the bypass
may be ours well there's emotional
support dogs which a greyhound could
absolutely be chase and I wanted our to
and I think we can accomplish it in 2017
the only thing is like I agree with you
with the rending thing and for right now
it looks like we'll be renting for at
least another year right I mean at least
so yeah we'll see though you like you
never know because we might have a
change in heart to where we decide to go
you know look at a greyhound adoption
and we fall in love with one and then we
decide that's what we're gonna do but
yeah you know after having Archer and
Sydney come over and stay the night in
finding them and just interacting them
how easy is that was it that was really
I mean we we could talk about wanting a
new dog as much as we wanted but having
to in the house like that so ridiculous
it was yeah that's kind of pushed us
over the edge huh I'd say that's my
biggest goal for 2017 figuring out how
to do it and making it happen and like
everything else I like though I get a
little nervous that when you have three
little dogs and then you have a big dog
that all of a sudden has slightly
different needs because it's a big dog
like we go to the dog park we can't just
take them all into that little area no
big guys got to go over to bigger yeah
let me got you in one side of me on the
other side just I go to the fence and
Tong's waves reaching oh I would love to
have a big dog park and like let her run
around blender stop we I just got to
stop like thinking about it in my mind
cuz once you have the dog and then
you're like oh this is my life now then
there's then you don't think about
anything just go we were just we saw a
dog a greyhound that looked exactly like
peach and we're thinking and aiming at
peach too and like you're just calling
them both peach no no peach and peach -
how confuse would they be though peach
peach champion teach Joe Kinnear and
beep and Boop and beep in boom what do
you want for 2017 I think I can get my
purple belt in 2017 I think that's a
reasonable goal I think I can do it I'd
like to I'd like Apple to get their head
out of there
us and give us phones that don't die by
noon Oh shots fired
no I'm like sick of it oh my phone has
to be charged by ammo fee or external
gain five times a day it's a joke in his
face and it's not it's not how my phone
used to be yeah it's like they're
releasing software updates that
overwhelmed my phone to the point where
it can't last hey Chad I hate that
that's my one of my resolutions but I
can't control what are your resolutions
is for apples yeah my new year's
resolution is keep my name touch em up
[ __ ] that's your resolution I get
people to keep getting out of it no um
um anything else that you want because I
have another conspiracy theory for you I
want I am going to be releasing a
collection of pins every single month
this year that's right I've seen the the
ideas you see that works yep and I made
of [ __ ] so pumped about it I think
since I know I'm gonna do that I think
my goal is to just further the pin brand
that I've kind of created right like get
deeper into the pin world so that's what
that pins area like really coming back I
love that they're coming back I love it
for so many reasons the Flair of it the
collector's items of it and you can
create something really cool and have it
be existing in a three-dimensional
object I also love that they're super
affordable yeah all right what's your
conspiracy I know someone tweeted does
that mean um
and I liked it just I like things up
anyways that the internet insists that
Sinbad played a genie in a movie called
Shazam did you do that
yes I saw that what the [ __ ] Shazam is a
movie it's a movie right people are
saying now it doesn't exist or something
yeah and well the reason I remembered
this yeah and it's funny when you see
this out was because when the app Shazam
came out yeah I was like weep aren't
they gonna have trouble with that trash
yeah and I looked it up when Shazam came
out and found nothing and I was like oh
my god I guess I'm just an idiot like I
guess it was cuz I'm shallow
yeah no it's just am no no no no there's
another movie called Kazan with Shaq or
whatever the [ __ ]
that's why I was like maybe I'm here
who's thinking of something else
but then I was like no that that exists
but I feel like that's how a lot of
these mandalas you know people are
saying maybe it's not nella they're
maybe we're just having you know
collective thoughts that never happen
but um I think that happens a lot with
people that discover sort of Mandela
effects your first response is like well
I must be kind of crazy then you know
like the Berenstain Bears yeah I
immediately feel like oh I'm not that
strangers dimensions a website that I
was the guy that I think originally
wrote about it
like literally detail of his thought
process of what was happening and he was
like I just figured that I was going
crazy you know because you don't there's
no proof of that sort of thing on the
internet because when you google when
the app Shazam came out and you google
Sinbad
Shazam movie literally nothing shows up
so you're like there's no theories or
Mandela effects that show up so you're
like oh I'm just a stupid person so how
does a movie that literally existed just
go from existing non-existing what if
you had a DVD of it no people if nothing
exists nothing on IMDB nothing on on on
but a lot of people remember was seeing
it including myself because I remember
physically like looking it up when the
app Shazam came out what the [ __ ] is
there a team of people scrubbing the
internet in the world of things like
this to just like I don't know but this
hold on no I'll dude I don't listen to
this though in trip towers says
Sinbad says he will do a genie movie
because of the Internet what earlier
this week New Statesman dug into a
bizarre phenomenon hundreds of redditors
who have decided a Sinbad movie called
Shazam in which the stand-up comic plays
a genie exists inspite there being no
real evidence that it does mine and so
God himself denying it he said it never
did that movie never happened Shazam is
one of a number of apparent collective
delusions being shared on
and Dulles subreddit named for a popular
shared misconception the former South
African president Nelson Mandela died in
prison now though it may become reality
just so people will stop talking about
it the New Statesman story interviewed
several redditors who genuinely believed
that they had seen the film or
physically how the VHS copy in the 90s
which they do their claims were
variously that the movie was recalled
because Sinbad considered in
embarrassment that the film was buried
due to a lawsuit from DC Comics over
their trademark for Shazam or that some
kind of space-time anomaly has occurred
and the only and only they could
remember that at one point the movie
really did exist
I feel the explanation yeah the last one
is a common explanation for the Mandela
effect and that's a little sci-fi for
most people taste that claim is
generally not a joke apparently these
fans have been so determined to prove a
negative for so long that it's
frustrated sin back after this week's
story went live and thrust the
controversy into the spotlight he's been
getting inundated with messages on
Twitter eventually he figured we can't
beat them join them and said he would
make the movie so we can close this
chapter and then from Sinbad's Twitter
okay for all you people who think I did
a genie movie well well haven't done one
yet but I'm going to do one so we can
close this chapter howdy is this
tripping you out yeah no I mean yeah
it's not nothing surprises me
it's weird them I'm so into this stuff
yeah by hot electronically flood of
course Shazam doesn't exist because
sighs look this needs to know your thing
it's the Mandela effect in action
there's no there's no actual logistical
way to just like scrub something out of
the history books like that like the way
Berenstain happened the Berenstain Bear
there's no way to [ __ ] do that you
can't go into people's houses and change
the cover of a book you can't go into
someone's houses and take a VHS copy of
Shiva Shazam you can't go on what if
someone had a poster of that movie
because there were movie posters and
it's just not there on their wall like
there's no way just Mandela that's no
way there's no way it's all Mandela no I
disagree do I agree I just
screw with the way I'm feeling you want
it to stop there weren't a stop bunch
disagree with your feelings hard enough
that it stops then you throw your
feelings up
imagine that you're like sadness hello
oh no I'm sorry
why are you talking to my father yeah
that that is [ __ ] those crazy when I
saw that one I was like holy [ __ ] yeah
because I remembered looking it up and
there was nothing yeah I wish that I had
thought of it later and looked it up and
then there was an explanation of the
mental effect because I'm like oh tight
I'm not alone yeah I need to do better
of when I think of these things writing
them down I mean that was a long time
ago let's do that right yeah wait just
write it down speaking of Dreams and
I've been I've started taking the s
knack brand of zma if you don't know
what I just said it's okay but if you do
you know what it said fact I knew it's a
Newseum a that I'm trying and it's the
made by the creator of Z MA and my
dreams have been Hollywood z ma z ma is
zinc magnesium of vitamin b6 it's a
supplement generally for men but for any
active person I've taken it you've taken
it you take it at night you take it at
night it helps you recover it helps you
get into a deeper sleep and wake up more
rested and I've taken it for years and
years almost like 10 years now probably
more actually but I just recently for
whatever reason only started the S snack
brand which is made by Victor Conti who
created zma as a supplement and this
this brand of the za is so much more
potent than any other read I've ever had
that my dreams have been so [ __ ]
vividly so real every single night I
take it so that was my lead into I'm
gonna keep I'm going to start keeping my
journal by my bedside when I'm a dream
not cast come out I have one really long
story you remember when I did it yeah I
woke up and I was like that dream was so
ridiculous I'm going to write everything
I can remember as fast as I can and I
have not looked at it since but it is
like you know couple scrolls where it's
on my note that part of what you have to
do is you have to write it all out and
then not look
the podcast so we can read them I'm
working on that either way I'll try to
do that to shake hands okay I don't want
to play pattycake dog with the foot Oh
bebe poufy um anything else you're
humping for our next year this year are
you pretty good with that I'm pretty
good I just want a dog
I want another dog or two and I want to
not rent our house because I'm sick of
our leaks and stuff but I do love our
house I love art I love living here
oh you sweet LLL make sure you
unsubscribe below like not a lot of
still not subscribe well Jimmy well keep
it going
thank you guys so much for listening to
another podcast yeah really appreciate
you guys and uh we are
I mean I'm speaking for myself but I
know Jen is we're very excited for
another awesome year of podcasting yes
so very excited to k17 we hope you guys
have a great week
check out the sponsors in the
description below and we will see you
next Monday
[Music]